i think gauze and buddhist fart
i'm sarah and i am 10 years old
i'm four and i'm toby by law i'm jewish
but i don't know if i necessarily
believe in it i
believe in buddhism i believe in god
for me it's a really big maybe part of
me believes in god a lot and the part of
me
definitely doesn't because maybe there
is someone upstairs you know
making great things happen and
sprinkling magic on the world
and then you see such bad stuff happen
and you see
kids get cancer and you're like you
doubt or
you question god we have this thing
and called kunyam it's kind of like god
but it's
like chinese in my religion
we call him allah he helps people
god is love i think god
has a soft voice i think he would sound
like
hoy i think since he's lived so long
it's kind of washed out
i should make good things happen to the
world
this sounds so creepy like a horror
movie i think it sounds
loud he sounds like really kind i think
well hello
you can see him on the ground
on his legs and on his feet
i think god is in the sky i pray
to the young to bring us
good luck and support my family usually
what i wish
for i'd like to spend time with my mom
all day i want to have confidence in god
if they control all of us i want to have
confidence
that i don't need to pray and tell them
to do it i think
they should make great things happen and
really prevent the
really bad terrible things one time i
went outside and i put
two guns so i could have flowers
if there is a god what is it like what
do they look like
god looks like a person maybe god's a
a woman or maybe god doesn't identify
as a gender they're usually gold or
white i think god will have green eyes
why do i always think of wearing a
hoodie i'm drawing him
clothes i don't really know if he has
clothes
because i can't draw him naked i was
wearing his a
masculine god
t-shirt gotta put that god on there
put some jewelry on his head he's in his
hoodie so we're not going to be able to
see his hair guys
i don't think he has hair i think you
know it's hard to
keep having hair if you've been alive
for you know this many millions of years
he's kind of self-conscious
about not having hair this one's shaped
like a monkey i
just would hope hope that he would look
like a regular person
this guy is a big head on legs
his hands are very long and big i know
how to make hands really
i think this sticker
he gives me a little coffee i don't
think he looks like anyone
i know i think he wears you know those
swag
green pants very cool green pants make
him a little more
colorful he's got those sick nikes on
he has a beard he has orange hair
angry knife he's big and he always sits
down he looks kind of funny
he has a blue shirt and blue pants
in very hairy arms i just would like
you to think of god a man or a woman or
whatever you want to think of god as
happiness you should have a big smile
when you think of god
and we're in those those second nikes
you know
thank you for letting me be in this
world
world goes round because all these
different people have different beliefs
in god and i love that
but i don't think that their belief
should cause wars
this could be someone fiction this could
be someone man-made i love that
everyone has a different view of god and
different beliefs in god
but i don't think it should cause so
much commodity or a war
i really don't hey unsolved is on a new
channel i know your part
subscribe here that was my part